[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
das Verbrechen ist das Ergebnis des
sozialen extrems Vladimir
illiachisches System erkennt man daran
dass es die Kriminellen verschont und
den politischen Gegner kriminalisiert
Alexander soll Chemie ziehen 14 Frauen
zu Tode gepeitscht Mörder in Polen
aufgehängt aus der Bild-Zeitung am 4 mai
1977 ihr merkt schon wir wollen euch mit
Zitaten ein bisschen einstimmen auf
unseren heutigen Fall denn es geht um
eine abscheuliche verbrechenserie im
Sozialismus genau gesagt im Polen der
1970er Jahre ich bin Toni Heyer und mein
Name ist Mirko Kasimir hallo schön dass
ihr dabei seid unsere Geschichte führt
uns in das südwestliche Polen wo eines
der größten kohle-reviere des Landes der
wichtigste Wirtschaftsfaktor war
der Fall ging in die Kriminalgeschichte
ein als der Vampir von Schlesien
insgesamt vielen mindestens 14 Frauen
diesen Mörder zum Opfer und bei Polen
damals zum sozialistischen Ostblock
gehörte hatte diese Serie auch
politischen Sprengstoff alles beginnt am
7 November 1964 in Kattowitz eine junge
Frau namens Anna muicek wird überfallen
und ermordet im Januar des
darauffolgenden Jahres geht es weiter
der unbekannte Täter überfällt allein im
Jahr 1965 11 Frauen ihre Namen Eva Lydia
Irena erdwiga Eleonora Sophia Maria
Genoveva Teresa Alice und Irena 6 von
ihnen sterben die anderen fünf werden
zum Teil lebensgefährlich verletzt wir
müssen uns aber erstmal darüber
unterhalten was genau passiert ist also
wie laufen diese Überfälle ab die Bild
schreibt später beispielhaft über einen
der Fälle
sie kommt von der Arbeit plötzlich hört
sich hinter sich das tappen schwerer
Schritte sie dreht sich erschrocken um
und sieht die stechenden schwarzen Augen
eines Mannes
sie schaut ins Gesicht des Vampirs von
Kattowitz etwas weiter heißt es wenn es
ihn überkam suchte er sich ein Opfer und
dass seiner Jacke hatte er eine aus
Stahlseilen zusammengedrehte
lederbezogene Peitsche versteckt an
Menschen leben dunklen Ecken fiel er
seine Opfer von hinten an und warf ihnen
die Peitsche wie eine Schlinge um den
Hals in anderen Quellen taucht die
Peitsche nicht auf sondern nur ein
schwerer stumpfer Gegenstand
einig sind sich die meisten Christen
darüber dass der Mörder zwar so wörtlich
sexuelle Handlungen an den Körpern vorne
an die Frauen aber nicht vergewaltigte
einige seiner bereits toten Opfer
verstümmelt der Killer im Genitalbereich
die Öffentlichkeit soll von alledem
möglichst nichts mitbekommen wir dürfen
dabei nicht vergessen dass es zu dieser
Zeit in Polen keine freie Presse gibt
und die Politik will verhindern dass ich
Panik unter den Menschen in
Oberschlesien ausbreitet wie am Anfang
schon die Zitate gezeigt haben
Verbrechen und Sozialismus das ist ein
wirklich schwieriges Thema also für die
Kommunisten denn Verbrechen sind ja das
Problem des kapitalistischen Westens
Raub und Mord gibt es dort wo die
Arbeiter ausgebeutet werden und die
einfachen Menschen um das täglich
Überleben kämpfen
der Sozialismus aber ruft das Gute im
Menschen hervor die ganz wenigen die
sich trotzdem ins kriminelle verirren
die werden von Vaterstaat erzogen aber
natürlich lässt sich gar nicht
verhindern dass sich die Morde
herumsprechen später kommt heraus dass
der staatliche Geheimdienst versuchte
Briefe in denen über die Todesfälle
berichtet wurde aus dem Verkehr zu
ziehen die Leute haben Angst Frauen
gehen in Gruppen zur Arbeit und zurück
damit sie niemand überfallen kann in
Kattowitz bildet sich sogar eine
Bürgermiliz um auf den Straßen für
Sicherheit zu sorgen der Mörder wird
jetzt Vampir genannt also in echt saugt
er natürlich gar kein Blut aber die
Taten die wirken so monströs dass das
Wort Serienmörder offenbar viel zu
harmlos scheint manche sehen im Mörder
sogar eine teuflische Erscheinung
vielleicht so mutmaßen sie wolle der
Mörder bis zum tausendjährigen Jubiläum
des Christentums in Polen
tausend Frauen töten das ist natürlich
Unsinn aber das morgen geht tatsächlich
weiter im Jahr 1966 überfällt der
sogenannte Vampir weitere Frauen unter
ihnen Genovefa Maria Juliana und Jolanta
sowie ein Mann Stanislaus der überlebt
den Überfall ebenso wie eine der Frauen
drei Frauen sterben aber eines dieser
Opfer stammt aus der Familie eines
Prominenten und mächtigen Politikers und
das macht einen Unterschied der Name ist
Jolanta gierig die junge Frau wird am 11
oktober 1966 in der Stadt beziehen 12 km
nordöstlich von Kattowitz ermordet sie
ist die Nichte von etwa direkt der ist
damals achtung hier kommt die sehr
sperrige offizielle Bezeichnung Erster
Sekretär des provinzkomitees der
polnischen vereinigten Arbeiterpartei
kurz gesagt schon damals ein wichtiger
Kommunisten Bronze
1970 wird der übrigens Regierungschef
zwar versuchen die Herrschenden noch
eine Weile jede Meldung nach außen zu
verhindern aber nach der Ermordung
jolantas nehmen die Ermittlungen jetzt
richtig Fahrt auf hilfreich ist das
zunächst aber nicht zum Beispiel gibt es
1968 die für damalige Verhältnisse
ungeheure hohe Belohnung von einer
millions Volti für Hinweise die zu
Ergreifung des Täters führen damit
könnte man in den 60ern in Polen gleich
mehrere Häuser kaufen also kein Wunder
dass plötzlich jeder jeden als möglichen
Mörder meldet
so gehen hunderte Hinweise ein die zu
nichts führen außer zur Mehrarbeit für
die Polizei man versucht sich damals
sogar schon an so etwas wie Profiling
Kriminalisten notieren lauter mögliche
Eigenschaften des Serienkillers und
erstellen daraus ein Profil mit 56
Persönlichkeitsmerkmalen
daraus wird eine Liste von Verdächtigen
erstellt unter denen sich tatsächlich
auch der spätere Angeklagte befindet
aber dazu kommen wir gleich noch der MDR
hat im Jahr 2022 eine ziemlich gute
Zusammenfassung des Falls erstellt und
darin berichten Sie dass polnische
Behörden zeitweise auch ein Kripo
Beamten aus der DDR hinzugezogen weil es
dort ähnliche Mordserien gab über eine
davon hört ihr in der nächsten Ausgabe
von Tatort Deutschland aber mit den
Fällen in Oberschlesien ließ sich auch
später kein Zusammenhang herstellen
typisch für Zeit und Ort also für den
Kalten Krieg und das sozialistische
Polen ist es das ist auch politische
Verschwörungstheorien gibt
so heißt es unter anderem es können ja
wohl kein Zufall sein dass ein Mord am
22 juli stattfand das sei ja der Tag der
Miliz auch der Tod der funktioniert
nicht der Jolanta wird als Indiz eines
Komplotts gesehen ja hilft aber alles
nichts auch im Jahr 1967 mordet der
Unbekannte weiter am 15 Juni stirbt im
Benjamin eine Frau namens Sophia mit Z
geschrieben am 3 Oktober bringt der
Täter eine Sophia mit S geschrieben im
Städtchen wojkowitze um den letzten Mord
der eindeutig in die Serie passt den
gibt es genau ein Jahr später also am 3
oktober 1968
Opfer ist eine Frau namens juddwigaik
dann herrscht anderthalb Jahre Ruhe
was dann folgt sind ein tödlicher Irrtum
und eine Denunziation beginnen wir mit
dem Irrtum
Werbung du Marius ja ich liebe ja die
TV-Serie julia Leischik sucht bitte
melde dich die schaue ich ja am liebsten
mit meiner Mama zusammen denn in dieser
Serie geht es darum dass die Julia quasi
um die halbe Welt fliegt um vermisste
Menschen zu suchen und Familien die
lange Zeit voneinander getrennt waren
die wieder zusammenzuführen und das
macht sie jetzt schon seit sage und
schreibe 18 Jahren und ich kann dir eins
sagen bei uns auf der Couch daheim
bleibt kein Auge trocken das kann ich
mir sehr gut vorstellen aber Rakel weißt
du was ich erzähle dir jetzt mal was es
gibt das ganze nämlich jetzt auch zum
Hören im brandneuen Podcast julia
Leischik spurlos echt jetzt erzähl mir
mehr jede Woche gibt es einen neuen
rätselhaften und emotionalen Fall ne wie
du das kennst Julia erzählt das zusammen
im Podcast aber mit ihrem schwierigen
Kollegen Michael Strasser und ich finde
hört man sofort das ist eine
eingeschworenes Team die beiden die sind
schon seit so vielen Jahren da zusammen
unterwegs fürs Fernsehen reisen um die
ganze Welt um diese Vermissten zu suchen
da hörst du einfach dass es natürlich
auch Freunde geworden sind aber nicht
nur die beiden kommen zu Wort sondern
auch direkt betroffene Angehörige
Kriminalbeamte Experten und die
schildern dann alle ihre Sicht auf den
Fall also liefern sie quasi einen Blick
hinter die Kulissen genau ja also man
kann sagen das ist so eine True Crime
wie sie da den Fällen nachgehen trifft
auf große Emotionen wie easy liebt da zu
Hause auf der Couch der Podcast julia
Leischik spurlos jeden Mittwoch gibt es
eine neue Folge also hört auf jeden Fall
rein und um keine Folge zu verpassen
abonniert julia Leischik spurlos
kostenlos auf dem Podcast Player eures
Vertrauens
Werbung Ende
am 4 märz 1970 wird Jadwiga kucianca mit
bloßen Händen erschlagen die Polizei
ermittelt einen gewissen piotta-ware als
Verdächtigen und nimmt ihn fest schon
bald aber muss er mangels Beweisen
wieder freigelassen werden
orschede der schon vor diesem Drama
psychisch krank war der dreht jetzt
durch er ermordet Frau und Kinder und
brennt seinen Hof ab bis heute ist nicht
ganz klar ob euch schon wer diesen Mord
von 1970 beging oder der Mann der später
als der Vampir von Oberschlesien
angeklagt werden würde und damit kommen
wir zu Denunziation im Januar 1972 zeigt
eine Frau namens Maria matschwica ihren
Mann bei der Polizei an
der ist Hilfsarbeiter in einer
Kohlegrube die Familie wohnt neben den
Angehörigen des ersten Mordopfers an
mich Jack Maria sagt aus dass ihr Mann
sie und die Kinder häufig schlage
außerdem neige er zu ungewöhnlichen
Sexualpraktiken und er komme regelmäßig
mit blutigen Arbeitsschuh nach Hause
also kurz gesagt sie sei sicher dass ihr
Mann dies war der gesuchte Serienmörder
sein müssen er wird also festgenommen
die Behörden haben endlich etwas zu
melden endlich den Fall gelöst und
endlich den Mörder der Nichte dieses
prominenten Politiker gefunden
und nicht nur das die Miliz nimmt quasi
auch den Rest der Familie in Sippenhaft
zwei Brüder werden der Beihilfe
eingeklagt die Schwester soll
Gegenstände der Opfer verscherbelt haben
Fall gelöst
die Mühlen der polnischen justizmahlen
erstmal erstaunlich langsam erst 1977
wird das Todesurteil gegen
vollstreckt das ist auch derzeitpunkt an
dem die Bild über den mutmaßlichen
Mörder berichtet die Redakteure von
damals beschreiben ihn als finster
dreien blickenden Gesellen mit einer
großen von Verletzungen schiefen Nase
aber viele Jahre später falt nach dem
Ende des Sozialismus in Polen werden
Zweifel laut
unter anderem vertieft sich der
Buchautor Champions
ein Buch über den Fall darin kritisiert
er unter anderem dass der Beschuldigte
g-sua my tricky im Prozess nicht mal
einen Verteidiger hatte das Verfahren
selbst sei ein Schauprozess gewesen für
den man sogar Eintrittskarten brauchte
er fand in einer Fabrikhalle statt mit
Platz für 800 Leute in den Verhören
durch die Miliz hätten die Beamten seine
geistige Schlichtheit ausgenutzt
matriki sei gar nicht klar gewesen wie
sehr er sich selbst belastet habe war er
also unschuldig dagegen spricht das
Tagebuch das Match Wiki in der Haft
schreibt darin gesteht er seine Taten
sehr detailliert und schildert eine
trostlose Kindheit mit einem Vater der
mehrfach verheiratet war und der Mutter
die sehr früh verstarb er sei kein guter
Schüler gewesen weil er lieber Mädchen
abschleppte als zu lernen
während des Krieges wurde er zur Arbeit
auf einen Bauernhof geschickt die Wirtin
erwischte March Wiki beim
Geschlechtsverkehr mit einer Kuh dann
fiel er der Gestapo in die Hände die ihn
schlug und in ein Arbeitslager sperrte
in seinem gefängnisstagebuch schreibt
man tricky außerdem dass seine Ehe mit
Maria nicht so gut lief er trank viel
und war ehrlich gesagt lieber mit seinen
Freunden zusammen als mit seiner Frau zu
Hause polnische Journalisten sind später
aber sicher dass der Häftling Match Wiki
gezwungen wurde so ein Tagebuch zu
führen und zwar mit Hilfe eines Zellen
Nachbarn der dafür sogar eine Verkürzung
der Haft erhalten habe interessantes
aber wie unterschiedlich die Verhaftung
des Angeklagten geschildert wird
ursprünglich hieß es matriki habe gesagt
jetzt haben sie den Vampir von Kattowitz
Recherchen ergaben aber das ist viel
mehr eine Frage gewesen sein soll
suchen Sie hier den Vampir von Kattowitz
ein ganzes Kapitel lässt sich übrigens
auch über matchwikis Bruder Jan
Schreiben der war schwul und er soll
viel intelligenter gewesen sein als
seine Geschwister Jan arbeitete als
Verwaltungsleiter an der juristischen
Fakultät der Uni Schlesien dort soll er
studienzulassungen gegen Geld vermittelt
haben ja Tiger kutschanka soll das
mitbekommen haben und daraufhin drängt
Sie Jan angeblich sein Bruder giswaff
1970 dazu
ermorden eben weil sie ihn belasten
konnte kein Wunder also bei den ganzen
Gerüchten dass es über diesen Fall in
Polen jede Menge Artikel Bücher
TV-Sendungen und sogar einen Film gibt
vielleicht war Match Wiki unschuldig ein
Bauernopfer vielleicht war er aber auch
der wahre Täter in einem Verfahren
voller Ermittlungsfehler dass das bis
heute unklar ist das ist die Schulter
Politik es ist eben nicht gut wenn sich
die Politik in die Ermittlung von
Kriminalfällen einmischt weil dies die
Unabhängigkeit der strafverfolg Behörden
und der justizuntergräbt die
Strafverfolgung sollte frei von
politischer Einflussnahme sein um
sicherzustellen dass die Strafverfolgung
fair und gerecht abläuft und dass die
Gesetze gleichmäßig angewendet werden
wenn die Politik sich in die
Ermittlungen von Kriminalfällen
einmischt für die besonders in
diktatorischen oder undemokratischen
Systemen zu einer starken Verzerrung der
Rechtsprechung da dann politische oder
persönliche Interessen und Ziele
anstelle von Fakten und beweisen eine
Rolle spielen können und das führt dazu
dass unschuldige Menschen verfolgt
werden oder das schuldige straflos
davonkommen Armen Mirko da habe ich
nichts mehr hinzuzufügen sehr gutes Ende
das war's für heute wir freuen uns
natürlich wenn ihr uns schreibt zum
Beispiel per Instagram oder per Mail die
Links dazu wie immer in den Show Notes
und wir würden uns auch riesig freuen
wenn ihr uns supportet und ein Kommentar
oder eine Bewertung da lassen das gibt
für die heutige Ausgabe hat Stefan
vorbereitet mit Infos aus polnischen
Medien wie chronikioff und Polski Radio
sowie einem Artikel des MDR und alten
Auszügen aus der
Bildaufnahme und
schnittproduktion durch weight watch
Studios München bis zum nächsten mal
euer Mirko und eure Toni